i could play football for the irish
y'all i could play football for the
hirers
catch me on tour tickets to all shows
are available on my website at ryan
sickler
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media if you are watching on
youtube thank you first of all and make
sure you hit that subscribe button hit
it lock it up and then set yourself a
little reminder alright it really helps
out the show
uh and if you got to have more you got
to check out the patreon the patreon is
called the honeydew with y'all all right
it's five bucks a month if you sign up
for a year you get a month free and
you're getting the honeydew a day early
ad-free at no additional cost all right
you get the audio feed you get the video
feed of the entire bat catalog
i know a lot of you saw the episode i
did with josh wolf where i showed them
just like 10 of our
favorite episodes i promise you there
are
a ton more where those came from and
uh really you guys like the reaction
show so i think we're gonna do that once
in a while because i'm telling you these
stories are
wild and every thursday we've been
releasing those episodes that we
highlighted on the episode with josh
wolfe uh on the regular youtube channel
so uh this week will be the fourth
episode um there'll be six more maybe
we'll throw in a bonus we'll see
um but uh you sign up to the youtube
you'll definitely see it there all right
my night pants nation tour continues
thank you all for your support we have
sold out at least a show or two in every
city we've been to so thank you so much
for that hollywood i'll be at the
troubadour june 4th josh wolfe just
added to that show des moines iowa june
24th one night only omaha june 25th one
night only i'm back at the brea improv
uh june 30th onenet only i'm bringing
jason ellis on that one with me all
right now you guys know what we do over
here i always say these are the stories
behind the storytellers i'm very excited
to have this storyteller back on the do
ladies and gentlemen please welcome back
yada's papas welcome back to the
honeydew thank you my friend good to be
here
third time third time bro second time
hey
two for two for three
the sequel's never as good as the
original
first one was amazing second one you
know we went on a little too long about
cover no we didn't no we didn't listen
to me
covert went on too long i still can't
smell and taste properly okay and kova
can go [ __ ] itself
we
it is it is hilariously it's one of the
most complained about episodes i've ever
done
uh the numbers didn't show that though
bro the numbers didn't show that yeah
that's what you call a good hate watch
yeah it was a good hate watch i hate
[ __ ]
and uh i'll tell you it was to me
the tale of two covets you're [ __ ]
almost dying your wife with a brand new
child i believe is chasing after an
ambulance and we're driving around
[ __ ] looking at lights and sinking
christmas carols dude
this is a great episode anybody in haiti
could go [ __ ] themselves maybe you don't
get a cult following like you know
you know like the honeymooners was a
bomb when it aired and then later on
years later it became a hit that'll be
our honeymooners um well it's glad i'm
glad to have you back it's good to have
you here please plug promote whatever
you'd like yeah uh my podcast long days
with giannis pappas uh so check that out
please on youtube subscribe and uh my
special is still up there for free to
watch on youtube blowing the light i got
a new special out now right now so go
check that out it's on youtube um
and um that's it man and see me on tour
yeah go to my website
yanuspapiscomedy.com for tickets that's
about it i'm always fresh with the new
tragedy for you so
you know
unfortunately unfortunately i'm
surprised this is not this isn't
anything small not that anyone's trauma
is small but this is
yeah this is a matriarch
yeah
yeah well yeah the first time i came i i
don't know what we talked about we
probably mentioned her dementia my mom
had dementia for a long time oh you got
shot we thought to beat you being shot
right all that stuff too right i mean i
maybe think you talked about your mom
having dementia and then second time was
the covet episode only strictly code all
covered all the time did we mention did
we mention my friend angelo passing his
stomach cancer and my old manager
getting murdered in his
it's the honeydew y'all
oh yeah so yeah my mom just died finally
but you know it's a long protracted
battle with uh
advanced dementia which is ugly
ugly
how long um
i'd say it really started
in like her seventies oh man how old was
she when she passed she was 90.
20 years ago yeah it's a slow decline it
started with like little post-it notes
here and there and
you know it was i would say it's
probably the thing that's affected me
the most
and yeah i've been shot and
but that was the thing that affected me
my career the most it was kind of
dealing with that
and um so i've got a million questions
to ask let's go back to can we go back
to the beginning of her dementia you
want to go back to coven
december 20 20.
um
the beginning of her
um dementia like
when does she start to realize it do you
were you close enough with her to ask
questions yeah okay yeah yeah i lived
there when when did she look at you and
go okay something's different never
never never that it never real she never
or she never admitted it she never
admitted it and that was her personality
she was real prideful so i think that
made it uh even harder like you know she
fought it all the way and she's not a
type person who would admit
any weakness or
you know
she just uh fought it and she would like
post-it note and deny it away what
reminders yeah
post note says lunch in the fridge on my
wallet every day for my daughter bro
now you gotta be nervous you might have
to get it to get a cat scan
it's brutal because like it's a gene or
something like they
when you do the 23andme now you can see
if you're prone to certain stuff is that
right i didn't know that yeah
yeah i gotta have to do it then damn it
i'd rather know
i you know it's like yeah you now with
your dna they can see all the stuff that
you have a chance of getting like
because it's it's tied to certain genes
and
obviously lifestyle turns those genes on
or off or sometimes it's bad luck or
whatever but i'd rather know i'm a guy
who wants to know if someone gave me the
opportunity to know what day i'm going
to die i'd want to know
i'd make some i'd make some different
decisions yeah of course yeah i want to
know i just didn't know you could get
all that information so now that i know
i'm going to do it because i want to
know too i want to know all that
honeydew brought to you by 23andme
do you want to know do you want to know
when you're going to die where are you
at
you want to know how you're going to die
that's two different websites y'all it's
when you how you gonna die calm and when
you're gonna die
yeah um
when do you first see a change in your
mom and how old are you at that time
yeah so the the change started like um
like around her 70th birthday you know
she was divorced from my dad she was
living alone in the house that i grew up
in which is like a bricktown house in
brooklyn and it's kind of like you know
everyone's gone it's just her there
and so
it it started around then and i was
living in an apartment like um
you know
close by
so i lived there for eight years like
kind of like six blocks away
and uh you know she would call and
you know she would it was it started
with like i thought it was like she's
just lonely she wants me to do certain
things i want to go take i want you to
come with me grocery shopping and stuff
like that
and uh so the behavior was like a little
weird it was like a little
i think her lifestyle probably didn't
help it you know what i mean she was
inactive
and slowly she just started spending
more time in just her bedroom little by
little any pets no pets no pets no pets
and at one point me and my ex-girlfriend
jessie jessie may lived there with her
while she was like declining oh really
like yeah there was times that we would
and we had three dogs together we had
like a pit bull this other dog which is
like a portuguese
portuguese pedango i think they call him
and she was like a mix and then her
little chihuahua
and my mother would like
uh like we'd leave or something and my
mother would like walk the dogs with
like the leash on wrong and somehow it
you know and those are big dogs and
she's like a tiny elderly woman with
dementia and she would forget if she
walked the dogs it became like a thing
it became the point where like when i
was living there and jesse may was
living there with me
at the home and i was there kind of
you know partly because of that
um
mainly because of that um there would
there would be she would just keep
coming in she would keep knocking on the
door and coming in it was things like
that like to check if i was there
because she forgot i was there
quickly that quickly it started to
really progress she leave the stove on
and leave uh like eggs burning she'd
burn all these pots so that's where it
starts to get dangerous right yeah and
then we she had a tenant so i just kind
of became like the de facto landlord but
she would start fights with the tenant
and
it was real difficult it was very
difficult
it got it went from there and it
progressively gets worse that's why it's
so
it's like chinese water torture the
whole thing
um because she was managing the way she
managed especially the prideful woman
that she was
but it was a dangerous situation there's
tenants upstairs with kids she could
burn down the house so i was living
under herself anything could kill
herself so i was constantly living these
past
you know
10 15 years just with this fear
you know
when i went to miami i took a tv job in
miami in 2013 me and my brother got like
a woman in there who would like spend
the day with her but she would leave at
night and so my mother was there at
night and um at that point 2013
she never called me we didn't speak
hardly ever
she kind of forgot that i was
my number that's when she forgot my
number didn't know where i was and
wasn't remembering to call that was the
beginning of when it really started
kicking about 2013. and when you would
call would she recognize who you were
yeah she would but she would forget and
might call me again and forget we just
spoke okay so it was that there she
didn't forget who i was
and that's a weird feeling but uh
all the time
no she did she forgot who i was around
uh
2015-16 when we finally were able to
move her to a
location getting moving her was a
nightmare you know she didn't want to go
she fought at tooth and nail and she did
yeah and we had to like renovate the
house around her in her room because we
had to like rent the houses out to pay
for um to pay for it to pay because you
know the the public facilities
dude the alzheimer's floors and those
public facilities in new york are
you realize you're like yeah anyone
who's against free healthcare i'm not
for you know universal healthcare i get
it nothing's free
once you once everyone's against
universal healthcare until
they [ __ ] need
it you know it's like everyone's
it's all selfish everyone's liberal
until they get rich and they're like all
right now i'm a republican same thing
with healthcare it's like everyone is
like oh i don't want that socialism
until you need it
and um we ain't getting free vaccines
yeah
we get free magazines
yeah
and um and we just underfund that stuff
and those facilities are just brutal so
you you want to get her in you know to a
place that's uh
that's good and you have to pay for that
did she fight it because
she didn't want to go or did she fight
it because she knew
there's there's no one's going to take
care of me in there
she didn't want to go she didn't want to
go she was a prideful woman doesn't want
to leave her house like old people they
don't it's it that problem i think a lot
of people have with old people they
don't want to change they don't want to
be in another environment they want to
stay at home they rationalize everything
away
it's um i just know there's people out
there who are dealing with this dealing
with a parent with alzheimer's it is
the brutality of it is hard to describe
and like if anyone's listening who's
going through it they i know what you're
going through it's there's no solutions
there's no way to fix it there's no way
to not worry
there's nothing that's going to help
you're completely overwhelmed
and
it affects your life in
one of the hugest ways outside of having
something wrong with you like a major
illness
that is imaginable all right
you 20 years was not a number i thought
you were gonna say yeah that's what it
was that's a long time from 70 to 90 is
when it is really when it started and
then it kicked in it got progressively
worse
until you know where it was where she
had no idea who i was i've heard about
these communities um
i don't know if they're
again look i know nothing i've heard of
things okay they float my way and i
probably retain about 25 of that which
is probably 10.
but
uh but i've heard of these um
communities where they can put um
patients with dementia and
they're like a very uh structured
area so they can walk to the store
and they go in and the people that work
there know
they're coming in they're helping them
with things like that so they can still
feel like they're
doing something and help maybe empower
them you know i don't know how many of
them there are out there but it doesn't
seem like there's a lot of no i wish
there were more that's amazing
the people who do those types of jobs
like i have the utmost respect for i got
a special needs brother
my mother had dementia for as long as
we've mentioned
you know my dad had cancer and he passed
away
um he was 91 so you know he had a great
life other than that but the people i've
been around that's recently so much
nurses and and caseworkers and people
who do that
it's just it's another level of human
being like it's just those are the
people that hold this whole thing up man
and they get no credit while we're
sitting there worshiping like some actor
it's like
those are the people who are valuable
those are the people who amen when you
need it when you really are down those
are the people the patience they have
and the job they do
is
is invaluable to you when you need it
and to our society and i just have the
utmost respect for what they do because
i've watched it and they've taken care
of my loved ones and it's just
it's beyond i i am beyond grateful
for them because
when you have a family member your
mother or whoever your father your
grandmother your grandfather who has
alzheimer's you can't take care of it
that's the and that's another thing that
hurts you you can't help
you can try but it's a pr you need a
professional then you have guilt
you have guilt then you have guilt about
not seeing your mom when she's in the
place even though she doesn't remember
you and it's painful for you to go
um so it's just it's it's a it's a world
of [ __ ]
and um the only people who know how hard
it is are those going through it and so
it's just um it's
i there needs to be like groups where
people can talk about just to feel like
someone else can relate to what they're
going through because i know it i know
exactly what you're going like anyone
who's listening to this has gone through
it i know exactly what you're telling
people i know
exactly what it is i know how helpless
you feel i know how overwhelmed you feel
i know how guilty you feel i know how
sad and angry you feel then you get
angry you you get in denial right
because like your mother's being
difficult and then you're like you don't
know if it's real you don't know if
she's you know and then if she's
resisting that's a whole other level of
frustration
and um
there's nothing that has affected me
more than that and it hurts your career
it hurts your relationships you get
angry
uh
your patience is gone because you're
dealing with something that's
overwhelming it got to the point and
this is the hardest point for me was
i'd be doing stand-up and uh well i'm
feeling this one
i'd be doing stand-up and uh
something that happens when you have
alzheimer's called sun downing so at
night the alzheimer's gets worse
for some reason and that's why they call
it sunlighting so everyone who has
advanced dementia alzheimer's or any
type of dementia sundowning when the sun
goes down they get more confused
and they just lose it they don't know
where they are and they start panicking
so when my mother started sundowning i
would be you know i work at night so
isn't that a great combination
you know so that's when i go to work is
when she would be at her worst
so she would uh call my phone and and
say like uh
you know i'm i'm trap i may even have a
message on there still because i just
kept it because it's the last time i
really heard her talking to me
and um you know i'm trapped in this
building you got to get me out of here
she didn't know where she was she was at
home in a room she's like i'm trapped
you gotta get me out of here and i would
have to go on stage
and she would keep calling with the same
with the same message she'd be saying
the same thing over and ago so it would
just be like 20 calls in a row so i'm on
stage telling jokes and i just
feel my phone vibrating over and over
again and i know what it is and i know
she's panicked i know she's in a frantic
state
um now here's my she's alone
does she not remember that she's called
and left that she does not remember
that's why you're getting 20 calls no
and it's coming in quick too because her
memory is that that gone and it's the
same message it's the same word for word
word for word wow same almost like
recorded pre-recorded the same message
yeah yeah
and that's what's going on in your
[ __ ] i'm telling jokes so you're on
stage entertaining an audience and
there's a whole nother world going on
inside yeah i'm just trying one lady is
trapped and i'm trying to car
partimentalize and like be funny and
like cheer these people up when like i
need cheering up you know so it was
really
it was a that's what that was towards
the end and then at that point like and
me and my brother it causes
strain on your me and my brother would
fight a lot it really is your only
brother i have one brain injured brother
and then my brother um
who's the one me and him primarily dealt
with all this for so long
and um so my brain injured brother
obviously wouldn't do them you just say
brain injure brother like it's like
everybody's got one you know and i mean
like um i don't know if i talked about
it on the first can't remember because i
already
[Laughter]
recently i've been thinking about how
great his life is though dude he just
has a van that picks him up everywhere
imagine living a life where you just
like there's just a van and all your
friends are in it all the time
and you're not going to like pay your
taxes you're doing anything you're going
bowling
his life is great he's got a girlfriend
he cheated on her he lifts his head up
for real yeah how old is he he's uh 56
now was he born this way or did
something happen i think we talked about
the first one but if we didn't get
tragic yeah if we did i don't remember
um either but he uh the doctor used
forceps on the birth and squeezed his
head i do think he did yeah i think i
might have done yeah
yeah if you didn't like the second
episode the first one was incredible
that was a great one number one was
incredible it was a great house listen i
stand by too yeah i i stand by too it's
a time stamp god damn it someday people
are gonna go back and be like look how
it affected different people
yeah
it was all new man we were only a few
months into that we were people so mad
about it
oh my god you know maybe that's what it
was like
i had just had covered when it was like
me too yeah i was like what are we going
to talk about i was like you just had it
you're telling me about how you're dying
i was like i just had them we were
[ __ ] having a great day we're
watching movies and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah i was i was envious he was like
damn that he had a great time
it's like when you have a friend and one
person likes him the other person has a
bad experience i think he's actually
like oh you don't know him man he's
actually pretty great
colby is a cool dude
um okay i want to go back to this so
that's going on in your pocket while
you're doing dealing with that it gets
worse at night which is something
yeah
all right tell me about your mom before
70 how old was your mom when she had you
she was 43 or four
little older a little older especially
back then right all right um are you the
are you the youngest a lot yeah okay by
a lot what's the next age 10 and that is
a lot 17. all same dad all same dad okay
so what happened with the they were
divorced so what were you
were you just an oops they got together
i don't know what i was i yeah like my
mom had a couple miscarriages before me
um
yeah i must i think i was a little bit
of an ups
or maybe my mom wanted me they never
really told me um
yeah i think my dad really wanted you
yeah i think my dad once
was too honest and he was like you know
your mom's the one that really wanted
you i'm like
you really
and i think
he wanted out
and then why'd he leave it in
[Laughter]
dudes went yeah but they can't stop
leaving today
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah if you want out just pull out
seriously that is all you gotta do man
i wouldn't be upset if i wasn't here i
wouldn't know
exactly um so tell me about your mom
what did your mom do like what's she
where she come from what's her
life like yeah she's got a very
interesting life my mother was born on
the island of crete greece okay during
uh
you know world war ii wow all right so
when she was little
so can you tell me her full proper name
her maiden name and everything full name
hannah mamalakis pappas wow all right
okay anna elaine memolakis pappas
and um so she was uh born in crete
um then world war ii happened and then
the nazis invaded
greece
and the battle of crete is one of the
most famous battles in world war ii it
was the first time that the germans did
an aerial invasion meaning the parrot
they used paratroopers it was the first
time any invasion had ever happened in
the history of the world
by air i didn't know yeah so the battle
crete the battle of crete is so
important because and she was there for
this that's why it's it's uh relevant um
the battle creek was important because a
lot of historians believe it was
important because
it actually took the germans 10 days to
take the island
to put that in context they took france
in like a couple of days the whole
country of france with millions and
millions and millions of people the
island of crete is an island
and uh the greeks fought like crazy like
she lost all her relatives were killed
there was new zealand troops british
troops there who had retreated off the
mainland and fought hard
um
and um so it's important because a lot
of historians believe hitler had to
um had to refocus
and and like had to really took a lot of
time to take greece and crete and that
postponed his invasion um
what was it uh
what was it whatever it was called to
russia to the winner and that's when he
marched into the winner
and so in retrosec retrospect the fight
that the greeks put up some historians
you know credit that fight with sort of
you know aligning with fate
um for that so that he invaded russia in
the winter and then that's where he
started losing
you know they froze and [ __ ] yeah you
can't invade rush and it was the same
aesthetic appointment so um uh they they
they famously fought very valiant like
the villagers fought and the germans
were brutal
and um like there was you know villagers
with pitchforks just like oh like
fighting with pitchforks as the nazis
came down just making shish kebabs out
of them
and so then they occupied for four years
after they took the island they occupied
so my mother lived under nazi occupation
for four years
um
she she saw horrible things she would
recount this story of like a um
a new zealand or uh australian pow being
marched through the village or the town
of rethymnone and she remembered once as
a little girl
one of them reaching for uh a fruit
because they were like so thirsty or
hungry like past the market and a nazi
soldier
beat that uh p.o.w to death death with
his the butt of his gun
and my mother saw that and she would
every time she would tell that story she
would cry
my mother ended up becoming a human
rights lawyer um wow yeah so she came to
america
um at a time where you know this is
she's the same age as ruth bader
ginsburg so at that
age at that place in history that time
there was like virtually no women going
to law school she she was one of four in
her entire law school at brooklyn
your mom's a pioneer yeah she was of
that generation so she became a human
rights lawyer ended up doing
uh international rights for children
work you know headed up a project called
um
uh
unitary it was unitary is it uh
the what was it called the law and
status of the child
is a big contribution to like
international law for children that she
she did she argued a case front supreme
court the united states supreme court it
was uh written but it was a case um and
she had four law degrees she was a very
proud
smart woman who uh who ended up doing
some good in the world with with her
advocacy for children
uh
specifically and she helped my father in
his law practice they were both both
lawyers and
so don't if you don't want to if you
don't want to get a divorce don't work
with your spouse that's just like too
much yeah i mean i guess it it i guess
it works in tom's case
but other people's as [ __ ] it's rare
yeah so this is a brilliant mind that i
mean if we're pulling out the human
element to it this is a brilliant
machine that's you're watching now go
kaput over 20 years brilliant in some
areas and others yeah right right yeah
but yeah i mean she was an accomplished
person and that was important to her and
um yeah
yeah and watching it just kind of yeah
decompensate slowly
rough
whoop did she was she able to retire uh
from work before the yeah is it a
disease
it's a disease yes the disease in the
brain um took her
yeah yeah she was able to retire on her
own she was done at like uh 65 i think
she got to enjoy a few years of life
before it really started to mess with
her yeah her and my father had a real
bad divorce
in her early 60s i don't know why you
get divorced at that point oh wow and
they're sick
and why is it ugly at that point you
feel like thank you
will you just sign here no problem it
was you can sign my name it was actually
very ugly into six why i don't my mother
is a fighter so it's like that's her
personality like when she had something
to fight
she's she's best when she has like
something to fight if she doesn't she'll
fight me she'll fight him she'll fight
she's a fighter she was a fighter i
don't know if she was molded that way
because i'm sure that informed who she
was
growing up in an occupied
you know nazi occupied country that's
gotta leave a mark that's gonna leave
that's gonna affect you in a you're
gonna be traumatized and she was young
so she was she lived during that like
she was like six seven eight those are
very formative years and maybe that
informed who she became like a human
rights
lawyer you know maybe that was part of
it you know the injustice of that and
having to live under military rule
you know i'm sure that had something to
do with it
and um
yeah i mean she used her mind a lot
and um then it then it started failing
her like it does for so many people
and i just it's slow it's slow like it's
like chinese water torture it's like a
slow
and it's very hard on everyone around
and i was just the one who was like
primarily around for it celebrate all
that you are and explore who you can be
with customizable prescription glasses
from pear eyewear all right you can
change up your look in a snap listen
they sent them to me and i'm being
honest with you i love them all right i
got the black like the
classic style frame and they're sturdy
frames okay they're not some cheap
flimsy frames uh the prescription
matches perfectly you just send your
prescription in boom they got it and my
eyes are they're not the best all right
and then you get the add-ons right so
uh you think they're going to be like
they're not like those old flip downs
you don't talk about where those ball
players are like flipping them down and
stuff nothing like that they actually
pop right on and because you can design
get different tones and everything they
actually look really cool they're
magnetic they clip on they're right
there got the blue blockers
all that i really do like them a lot all
right and base frames start at just 60
dollars and that includes prescription
lenses there are hundreds of top frame
designs to match whichever base frame
you choose get glasses as unique as you
are one pair infinite style starting at
just sixty dollars go to pair eyewear
dot com slash honeydew for fifteen
percent off your first purchase that's
fifteen percent off at p a i r i where
dot com slash honeydew i'm telling you
if you're looking for new glasses right
now you gotta check them out this
podcast is sponsored by better help life
is full of twists and turns stress
changes grief moments of growth and
moments where we feel like we're taking
a few steps back and it's important to
show up for yourself through all of the
struggles that life can bring better
help online therapy is here for the
twist and turns and will assess your
needs and can match you with your own
licensed professional therapist in less
than 48 hours
uh look you know i'm a believer in
therapy i think that if you're looking
for someone to talk to you definitely
should all right mental health
everybody's out there working out their
abs and their muscles work that mind i
promise you it'll pay dividends it's not
a crisis line okay it's not self-help it
is professional therapy done securely
online and the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist and you can schedule
weekly video or phone sessions so you
won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available better help is a great way to
show up for yourself and invest in your
well-being because well you deserve some
inner peace visit betterhelp.com
honeydew that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 2 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using betterhelp that they're
recruiting additional therapists in all
50 states special offer for the honeydew
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com honeydew that's
betterhelp.com
honeydew for 10 off your first month for
most of us learning a second language in
high school or college wasn't exactly a
high point in our academic careers all
right i took spanish 101 and 8th grade
got all the way up to 11th grade where i
started getting a d started dropping my
gpa and you're not gonna mess my 3.0 up
because that's a good student discount
on my state farm insurance now thanks to
babel the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscriptions
there's an addictively fun and easy way
to learn a new language whether you'll
be traveling abroad connecting in a
deeper way with family or you just have
some free time babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons that you'll actually
use in the real world i chose spanish
again because
i tried it before and i wasn't great at
it just went to mexico and my espanol is
muy bien
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go and other language learning apps
use ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective and with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german plus
babel's speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and your accent there are so many ways
to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcast games
videos stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee start your new language
learning journey today with babel right
now save up to 60 off your subscription
when you go to babel.com honeydew that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
honeydew for up to 60
off your subscription babble language
for life now let's get back to the do
what surprised you the most about it
um
what it actually is is hard to believe
when you're dealing with it well at
first when she's like when something
happens you don't think
anything's wrong you know like everyone
forgets something here or there you know
and like uh
you know uh my mother would guilt-trip
me a lot so i thought maybe it was like
she was guilt-tripping me or
you're in i was in denial about it i
didn't deal with it well for a while i'd
get angry at her
um because i felt like she was doing it
for attention or whatever and i have
guilt about that i have a lot of guilt
it's a very confusing thing
because it happened so gradually
at the beginning you you brush it off
so i think maybe that's what surprised
me most about it is just how hard it is
to detect that first or to believe or
how it creeps up on you it's not like oh
i have cancer or like you know it's just
like a very progressive
it's a progressive
disease that consumes
more and more and more and more so
um
i would say that yeah just like
not believing it at first was the most
surprising thing about it and
and how it progresses is kind of
surprising too how it goes from
like i said a post-it note here to
no no my mother didn't know who i was
she died uh
about a couple weeks ago
whoa yeah yeah
yeah she
died two weeks ago she just passed she
just passed oh man yeah yeah i'm sorry
dude i know you're coming here fresh off
fresh baby i came fresh on cove and i'm
coming fresh
i'm like i got it that's how we do it
now that's what comics do they go
when i have something horrible happen
which podcast can i go directly to to
talk about it
when the scar is fresh man i'm sorry
thank you man yeah it was uh it was it
was two weeks ago
and i also we're coming off a covid so
she was in a nursing home
um and so i didn't see her for two years
so i also didn't see her again yeah so
and then i finally went um
[Music]
let me hold on it for a second
i finally went and uh i have a daughter
now who's a year and a half and um she
looks a lot like my mom she does she
looks terribly
close it's like scary
and um so uh all i could do we didn't
bring my daughter because covet or
whatever and
my the last time i saw my mom she was
out of it like i have videos and she's
just staring off and she's like at the
beginning of dying
she's still in the wheelchair at that
point so we just roll her around you
know she was at the point where they
would feed her you know they'd have to
feed her she couldn't remember to chew
and it would be like soft foods and
you can't remember to choose i can't
remember if it starts infecting you like
that where you're just done your
vegetable my mom was close to a
vegetable oh yeah and it's not remember
to chew so then ultimately do we
if you have that disease do you not
remember to breathe is that what i
actually think it can start happening
yeah that i don't i i assume that can
happen wow i don't know but that's like
involuntary i don't know right right so
i don't know
no i think you maybe still breathe but i
don't know that's a good question
but definitely the chew she didn't know
how to chew
so they would like force her to chew or
they'd do things and
um it's it's those floors
they're always locked off because they
don't want them to wander so there's
codes for the elevators and stuff and
those floors are tough
that's a tough sight to go into and i
have guilt but you know there's a lot of
me also that just didn't want to see it
i know she doesn't remember me anymore
and it's like
i mean covid i it was kind of a little
bit of an excuse like i could have gone
there and masked and stuff but
you know uh part of
when you your mother gets to that point
like when she died i wasn't that upset
because she was a kind of already gone
for me it's like you
you almost celebrate the death because
you don't want to watch anyone live like
that because it's so brutal to watch
right and so uh it was a little bit of a
relief like it's over like she has no
quality of life
and um so you have a little guilt about
that
and um
it's there's just a lot of real
confusing emotions that uh
that you go through and um dealing with
it
and um
it's one of the worst things there's no
way to sugarcoat how
how torturous and brutal it is
and i think the only comfort you can get
is talking to somebody else who's going
through it or i know there's someone
hearing this who's going through it
going like they know exactly what i'm
talking about and it probably feels very
good to hear
that they're not alone
and that's important to know like you're
just you're not alone somebody knows
what you're going through because i felt
so
alone it's very rare you have someone
else who you meet who's gone through it
or knows someone who's going through it
or you can talk to or hear about it it's
just you know it's just comforting to
hear that oh yeah i'm not alone in that
struggle do you um do you remember the
first time she didn't remember you
i don't know i don't i probably blocked
it out yeah and when she doesn't
remember you does she misremember you
like yes misremember but
are you are you joe the butcher or
something you see what i'm saying or are
you all okay a relative but always the
same person or never yeah just like
always something one phase it was like
i'm a relative
and then she was so prideful my mother i
think she would pretend to know who i
was even at that point would you give it
to her would you help her yeah make her
earn it
getting warmer give me one more guess
i came out of your vagina
[Laughter]
that would be hilarious that would be a
hilarious game show
that'll be hilarious
all the contestants have advanced
dementia and you're like okay welcome to
is that my son
welcome to who am i
and it's just people with dementia and
former football players with c-e-t
foreign
vh1 instead of where are they now you
can do uh where am i now
welcome to welcome to where am i now
with wes walker
oh god wes walker at my mom
um okay so it's always a random relative
but but in the
she could feel the at least get that
like you were family somehow i think so
okay i think so yeah yeah is there
anything that she did remember all the
way through
a tv show anything that that you know
what i mean like a favorite book or
nothing else nothing god your whole
memory because it's nothing the whole
memory goes and she was a very um
and usually a lot of times those people
get very mean
is that right yeah that's why i have now
that i've been around old folks home so
much it's kind of like a joke but it's
kind of true like
you can't really judge if someone's a
good person or not when they're younger
because we have so many things going for
us
you know it's easy to be a good person
if you're john stamos what is he you
know
what has he got to be upset about you
know it's like
he's given everything
good looking talented smart it's like
justin timberlake if he was a dick you'd
be like come on guy
what are you a dick about right what are
you bitter about when someone's either
sick or older and they lose they're
vulnerable and they lose all their
powers they're not beautiful anymore
nobody wants to [ __ ] them anymore if
they're still nice then
then they truly were a good soul you
know because a lot of people you're like
you meet him when they're young he's a
good guy and then he sees later he's
[ __ ]
calling everyone the n-word and because
dude i mean old people
the racism is nuts i heard about it yeah
it all comes out
there and these people still take care
of them that's why they'll take care of
them that's why these people are such
beautiful people they still after
getting like berated
berated and called the most awful things
they still do it and uh my respect is
just it's crazy
but um
yeah that's how you just can't you don't
know if someone's good until you see
them later and i knew she was a [ __ ]
yeah she was hiding oh yeah i told you i
always knew my mom actually was nice she
was a little tougher when she like had
her faculty she was a fighter like i
said
um and uh she was like nice the staff
was like she was pleasant she was quiet
and
you know because my mother was a very
anxious overthinking person and i think
there was part of it part of the silver
lining i guess is like she didn't
remember what she was stressed about you
know yeah it's like there's silver
lining everything you know i mean man
what um
what age do you have to take your keys
away
oh man yeah 2016.
so 2016 was when like those calls were
happening every night and i said to my
brother i'm like and me and him it it
affected our relationship and anyone
who's listening it's like
just it's hard because you guys are
going to go at each other's throats your
siblings and you're going to feel like
i'm doing more than you're doing one of
you is going to feel burdened the one
who's there is going to feel burdened
and it's not fair i'm doing all this i'm
shouldering all this so my brother
didn't he lives in dc
so i was shouldering a lot of the
day-to-day he did a lot of other stuff
that maybe in retrospect i didn't
appreciate
because i was dealing with uh
i was i was a soldier on the ground so
to speak he was doing a lot of the
arrangement all the stuff she made
he was parachuting in and parachuting
out
[Laughter]
he was parachuting in
and i if i had a pitchfork i would
[ __ ] do it i would stick we we really
fought a lot and it really hurt our
relationship and
you don't realize it till later like oh
this was all because of this it was
because we were stressed out dealing
with this anyone
would be short with one another it's
almost impossible
to uh to not start to resent the person
for this that the other thing because
you're just constantly under stress
so it was 2016 when it was like i was
like i can't we can't do this anymore
she needs were you able to take the keys
before there were accidents or we have a
couple sides
dude there was accidents man like the
dog like when jessie may was there with
me it was the the dogs like i don't know
how she didn't get like just yanked she
would put the leash on backwards and
like a 55 pound pit bull somehow
nothing bad happened um
she would leave groceries outside uh the
stove was huge the stove thing she would
cook eggs and then i'd come over and the
stove had obviously been on for hours
gas stove because the eggs were
evaporating it was just burnt at the
bottom of the pot
um
i mean specifically any car accidents
were able to take her keys before she
didn't drive thank god okay so she
didn't drive
and um
she wandered once or twice and a
neighbor
brought her back it's so brutal
now i'm remembering the
the brutality of it
like everyone on the block started to
know she would walk around in her robe
she'd go outside
you know it was just uh oh god and then
this part oh man this is
this is another yeah
oh this is she would donate to charities
over and over again and they don't stop
oh no yeah i mean she's i should be is
there not a law to [ __ ] prevent there
is preying on people like that they do
they do because when you give they keep
sending because you're giving
so i don't know how they must know on
some level or a little bit or
you know so it was like by the time we
caught wind of that man i caught wind of
it i was the one on the ground and that
was another thing the frustrating thing
my i knew it was bad my brother would
always because my mother was so
good at hiding it and being
prideful that he
would be like it's not that bad and
thought i was being dramatic because we
weren't getting along
um but it got to the point where i
discovered like i mean we're talking
about like
maybe
30 to 60 thousand dollars just gone no
yeah she was giving hundred dollars over
and over dude the numbers you're
throwing at
the 20 years no exaggeration no
exaggeration 30 to 60 no exaggeration
yeah this isn't [ __ ] la [ __ ] this is
new york i'm wow
and you can't go after these people i
guess not because they're doing it
they're sending the money she said just
sending the money each time she's
probably forgetting totally it's
probably her first time donation every
time totally for her and i'm sure that
happens a lot wow i should have never
thought of something like that i know it
happens a lot it probably happens with
like people selling the house there was
somebody stopped by wanting to buy the
house so you're living under this
constant fear of like is she gonna
[ __ ] sell the house right yeah
um
it's uh yeah i think that almost came
close to happening once if i'm i there's
so much you block out because it's it's
a constant 24 hour a day
worry somewhere in your brain it's
somewhere you have to live your life
knowing
that you know when she got into that
uh alzheimer's floor shout out to atria
it was like
knowing that
other people professionals were watching
her and it was a great place and we
figured out all the that's another thing
is all the [ __ ] stuff you got to
figure out you got to get everything out
of your name to be eligible for uh
medicaid to pay for it you got to get
everything out of her name so she has no
assets because it'll take all that to
pay
if you have some with alzheimer's go
talk to an elder care lawyer
now figure it all out
it's a you got to get all those great
advice i didn't even know that existed
yeah you got to do that you should do
that if you have lawyers for elder care
do it now like if me and you have kids
like set that [ __ ] up now you can do
that now you could [ __ ] do that you
so you know about like your will all
that stuff is all kind of just like
taken care of and like there's no issues
because with um for medicaid to pay for
it you need a five-year period where she
doesn't have assets
like they have it's called a five-year
look-back period so in that five years
she can't have any assets because then
they won't take that [ __ ] yeah first
they'll take it all
so it's uh and my brother was doing a
lot of that and i'm grateful that he did
because that's a [ __ ] mess you got
lawyers and and of course my mother made
her will while her dementia started so
her will was a [ __ ] mess her will was
like
she put it in a trust and made herself
the trustee
which is like a nightmare any like it's
hard to explain but it's a nightmare we
had to undo that trick her to sign
you know
she was holding on everything so i had
to take her checkbook
she got mad about taking her checkbook
she said she wasn't doing that i was
trying to show her proof a lot of anger
a lot of fights
and um because when you're in it you
don't go oh she doesn't know any better
you get frustrated because you're trying
to
stop this tragic thing from happening
and she's preventing it so we're all
human
and uh
i got mad at her i would get mad at my
mother it would be like i'd get angry
and feel anger towards her and like
throw things and
you know throw things in the wall
because it's frustrating like she's
destroying everything and you can't stop
it and then you also can't help her
because she won't let you help her
so it's like you just feel helpless and
overwhelmed so when we were able to get
her in she we tricked her into it and
that's the way you do it
the way you do it is you drive her there
right like we did a few where they
interview her and she was just nasty to
them then i'm fine they would ask
questions who's the president they like
interview her
um
but would she know any of that she would
know a few of them at that point 2016
she still
could fake it a little bit but then
he would get her on a few and she'd get
angry
and really like
really like uh
you know i can't find the word but
uh whatever it is she would just be
defensive
and get angry and it was hard so we had
to trick her into it we had to renovate
the house around her so she was in a
room and we would like renovate and then
it got to the point where we had to put
a baby gate on the stairs because you
know she could fall down the stairs
right so food was brought up to her we
had somebody coming in
you know she didn't want we didn't say
she was a nurse you'd have to say this
is a friend like it was this whole thing
and then this guy's renovating this
house um
and how did you how did you trick her
into going in we just drove her there
what you do is you drive her there show
her introduce you don't tell her what it
is you pack everything get it you know
you don't you pack things
and and
and you leave it's all so sick and
twisted and
sad that they're walking into a building
and i'm sure has the [ __ ] name right
on it and [ __ ] atria residency i mean
yeah
man so you leave so what you do is you
just uh and they're used to it that
that's how it's like the best way to do
it it's like preschool bro you drop them
off watch them cry
i love you
it's so weird how sick how circular it
is
it's like she did that for me
and i had to do that for her she took
care of me and then i had to take care
of her it's crazy george carlin's got a
great bit about how we should um age in
reverse how we should start old and be
able to know that
so funny yeah it's true and you're like
wow
you know it's so [ __ ] true it's so
true
it's a great joke it is so you go there
and then you get on the floor and then
you're like oh we're just gonna have a
snack or whatever they distract her and
then we just leave without saying
goodbye what's that like is it we you
and your brother
yeah me and my brother did it together
it was hard that was hard
it was hard because you don't know who
these people are you know she's gonna be
scared and confused and they just tell
you like we're professional we're used
to we know how to redirect them
and now they're dealing with that her
not knowing where she is and so there's
a little bit of a relief because i know
she's with professionals right so now
the house isn't going to be burned down
and things like that but it's not a full
relief because now you got a new stress
of what the [ __ ] happening inside that
building yeah and let me just say this
it's important and i will admit it
and this is what's hard for people i'm
stressing yeah
and this is the thing is it's hard for
people to admit
because you feel bad you feel like a
piece of [ __ ] for it
is that you feel good the burden's no
longer yours
you know and you're guilty about feeling
good for us the guilt is real
the guilt is real and it's more than a
second
it's more than a second it's like a
really good feeling
that you don't have to shoulder that
anymore and uh
the guilt is real you you because look
you're leaving your mom
with
strangers she's you're not taking care
of her you're not there to know they
could be abusing her you don't know
what's happening
you know and you're you know she's not
happy and upset and going to be scared
and
but there's also this feeling of
a selfish feeling of uh
now my life will be a little easier and
that feeling is tough
it's easier to talk about now but at the
time it tears you apart it rips
absolutely rips you apart
it rips you poor so that brings on a
whole other
issue and that issues guilt and you feel
that every day i would feel a little bit
every day that i wouldn't see her and i
wouldn't go
you know
who knows she could be getting hit and
then your imagination goes to the worst
places the worst cause those people i
know i got angry dealing with her and
i'm her kid
and i got to that limit imagine being a
stranger and having to deal with her and
and
who knows oftentimes you hear horror
stories that happen in those situations
so
it's rough it just takes a toll on you
and you know
those you know there was one
one weekend i don't know if i talked
about it did i talk about when i got
carted out of uh
on a stretcher for what we didn't talk
about that i don't know who knows
at the uh there's two episodes at the
comedy connection in rhode island
i just uh panic attack or something yeah
i was i felt like i was gonna pass out
and um and then they they ended up
taking me out of the club on a stretcher
which is when there's nothing wrong with
you and you're carted out in a stretcher
it's really funny
dude sold out crowd give it a thumbs up
yeah i did actually
because you know how embarrassing it is
too like i'm on the stretch they're
calling me out the audience stood up and
they were giving me like an ovation like
i was an athlete like i was an nfl
player who got up
one guy handed me like a religious card
it was
you know and it was like
this is
he's
you know this was and we had sold we
were selling me and chris had started
history
fans i sold there was fans there and
they canceled the whole weekend this was
the first show no
i was on stage 30 seconds and it hit me
ah i went up there 30 seconds like holy
[ __ ]
and it was just like did you drop i
didn't drop but i got off stage like
because i knew i was gonna drop so i
said i was at first i was like i need a
chicken finger or something i thought my
blood sugar was low river because i
didn't eat and then like i got a chicken
finger it wasn't going away and then i
just was like i got to get off and so
the host came back on and the host and
the feature alternated doing time while
i was in the back like drinking water
trying to make it go away and then
finally uh one of the owners at the
comedy connection was like should i call
an ambulance and i was like i didn't
want to i was trying to fight it but i
was like i think so cause like you're
when you're in a panic attack you don't
know you're like oh my god i'm dying
so you know i got in there of course
they're like new england [ __ ] who
picked me up yeah where'd you bomb you
have a [ __ ] hard time
is this your first time doing comedy kid
and i'm laying in the stretching like
you know looking at all my they know
everything's fine
and then i get there and i thank god the
doctor was really nice the emergency
room doctor she was like she was a woman
she was younger
and she's like what's going on in your
life
and i told her i i and it came out
because i you hold it all in you don't i
wasn't going to therapy this time you're
just dealing with it until it explodes
like that hits you at a moment
and i told her and she was like
like wow she was like
wow and she was like here's here's
what's going on like she was like i'm a
medical doctor but let me explain you
got
a lot going on right now and you're not
dealing with it you're not taking care
of yourself
and this is the result of that she was
like and then she did the oxygen mask
kind of analogy which is true
and uh you got to put your mask on first
before you can i see you know when
you're dealing with everyone else's [ __ ]
you're just falling apart
and um
that helped
because i always thought of that and i
thought let i wasn't i stopped beating
myself up with so much guilt after that
because i was like i got to take care of
myself first because the guilt is so
real and so
ubiquitous and pervasive and constant
until you hear that it's like oh it's
okay for me to first think about me so i
can
do whatever i'll do yeah i'm allowed to
do that it's not a bad thing
so let me ask you this thing because i
really wanted an honest opinion it's
been two weeks i mean
that would be funny if right there would
you like if you were just like how's my
hair look
let me ask you and i just want an honest
opinion
is my is this barbara killing it or what
that's my hairstylist tara what's up
terra um
how do you feel i mean you when you
talked about like
it lasts a little longer when you put
her in a home because there's this
relief that hey she's being taken care
of by professionals i can't i think
about that when i fly you know what i
mean when the turbulence is the same
thing yeah like i it's not like i can
walk up in there and like move like i
can fly
you know what i mean i can do that
driving [ __ ] you guys don't know what
you're doing yeah yeah you just gotta
[ __ ] trust that it's in their hands
and everything's gonna be fine
so
she just passed two weeks ago
it's 20 years you're watching the demise
of someone you love dearly
what how do you feel is there a sense of
relief yeah there is and is there
massive guilt sitting with that also a
little bit but not less or less
less it's less because uh i'm in therapy
that helps
and i think because of the experience
with all that guilt
i know that like hey i'm human
you know
i can't ignore that reality like the you
know
we're all a little selfish and that's
okay i think it's actually normal to be
selfish people who aren't selfish always
end up getting a little weird you know
those people are too concerned about
society and then they end up becoming
dictators and murdering people because
they're so
tied to their utopian vision of how
things should be and there's a real
denial of reality in that you know and
so that ends up
going to a bad place so it's okay we're
selfish we should be we that's we're we
want our own survival first and that's
part of it that's part of it
um
you know it's your mom so you have this
guilt because a mother's love is
selfless
but i'm not a woman
i'm not a daughter what can i say i'm a
son i you know i guess daughters maybe
women are have that more
um there was a big relief man
a relief i can't even
i can feel it already just in my career
in my focus in in jokes i can feel it i
can feel a freedom that i have never
felt 20 years 20 years have you been
done stand up that long yeah so from the
beginning of this pretty much your
career this is pretty much going on
pretty wow yeah pretty much for the
majority of it pretty much yeah
yeah it's been there the whole time
so yeah it's uh there is a there's just
something there's a freedom and a a lack
of anxiety that's there that's not there
anymore
like when she died there was just this
relief oh and then there's all the whole
headache of the house and the tenants
and all the [ __ ] me and my brother had
to [ __ ] do and all the paperwork he
had to do you have to keep showing to
medicaid you have to keep
doing that how is that right you have to
keep yeah it's like you know it's a
whole thing keep proving you're poor
keep proving your point
you make a [ __ ] make anything yourself
yes
yeah it's a that our system is not good
i i believe in universal healthcare i
just think it's something taxpayers can
do
it's the right thing to do i don't want
to get too i understand the problems
with it but you know we do spend a lot
of money and i'm not i'm not a
progressive in a lot of other areas but
when it comes to these things i look at
with us being the only country in the
first world that doesn't have it i'm
going like maybe we're the [ __ ] on
this one
every other first world country has it
um i know
i know the problems with it i get it
but i think they're greatly outweighed
by the positives like you know
because right now it's just like poor
people get it
get because poor people get it right
rich people don't need it and people in
the middle get [ __ ]
you get [ __ ] and my story is one of
the middle most of the stories most of
the stories are the middle you get
[ __ ] if you're poor that you they pay
for it if you're rich they're like they
don't [ __ ] they pay for it so it's
like everyone in the middle gets [ __ ]
on this
so the only people that don't get paid
to die the poor get paid to die the rich
can afford to pay to die and we just
[ __ ] die dude and when you get sick
or whatever and you're in the middle
dude in this country you got to sell
your [ __ ] house you got to do [ __ ]
that trust me you you're not thinking
about or you have no experience with so
whatever your opinions are probably
those opinions are not based on
experience because when you experience
it you're going like dude we should have
universal health care there should be a
better system in place to take care of
old people
that's we're civilized are we not like
that's we i have no problem paying taxes
for that like if i knew it was going to
take care of
society yeah hopefully we're one of
those people someday that gets taken
care of good i don't want to do this to
my kids right
so let me ask you then because we're
going to wrap up here in a little bit
but you and your brother are you guys
going to
actively work on trying to repair things
or are you
good to go now that this burden has been
removed we are we had a big uh it
actually after covid me and him had a
big heartfelt i was crying
crying crying crying i was in a
vulnerable state after what i went
through with covet and we had am
i i just apologized you know i just we
had a huge
cathartic
reconciliation and i probably feel best
about that that's probably something
that
because you don't want to go through if
you don't want to be fighting with your
siblings because that's all that's all
that's my family now that's all i have
is him and now we got to take care of my
other brother he's in the program thank
god but we got to take care of all stuff
all the time so
um it's just not worth it with your
family family is all that matters all
the rest of this [ __ ] is just
things that you do to kill time you know
when it comes down to it
so i am most happy about that that we
are we've never been closer things are
great and i will never do anything to
jeopardize that even
he could be a little difficult
let's be honest
you know
he's like me and him are different he's
like uh you know he's like an a-list
kind of like he went to oxford
georgetown law
he's the oldest brother so he's a little
you know anal and i'm the hey man it's
fine i'm a comedian i'm like yeah
whatever you know we're like
so we're different and sometimes he
could be a little hard to deal with and
i am absolutely resigned to just take it
whatever it is
i'll take it i will not like it doesn't
matter to me like and i'll feel it too
i'll be i'll feel that thing i want to
shoot back i want to
you know because unfortunately we
learned that in our family from my
parents that was a little bit of their
flaw sometimes we fight hard and i just
like i am like i consciously will
override
i will like veto like the president i
will veto the congress which is my
[ __ ] what i'm feeling and go like
i'll look at the big picture and be like
this relationship means too much to me
for the rest of my life i'll just take
this right in the ass i'll take it like
a good grief and he's gay so it's
appropriate
[Laughter]
not only are we greek he is gay
not the original greek
brother thank you for coming on here i
know that wasn't easy to talk about and
i it's so fresh man i am i'm sorry for
your loss i mean by the time this comes
out maybe you'll be healed it's gonna be
a second yeah it's gonna be a little
while dude this podcast is special for
that reason like if you that's this is a
unique experience i actually it felt
good to talk about good thank you
because i haven't talked about it you
know it happened two weeks ago and uh
it just feels good to talk about it
admit some of those things that are that
you know thank you thank you that kind
of you know you you you know you have to
put in perspective and
i'm i'm happy i was happy to talk about
on this because this has a big audience
and it's going out and i there's people
going through it it's going to help
dm me if you're going through it if
you're not don't dm me don't protect
yeah don't pretend like you're going
through it just because you know i'm
going to respond because i will respond
but if you're going through it you want
to dm me and ask me any question about
it like if it's fresh for you going
through it just dm me on instagram
and i'll i'll tell you my experience and
i'll help the way i can through
experience only but i do know how hard
what you're going through is it's no
joke
well please again plug promote
everything you'd like
uh yeah just uh my special if you have
if you like comedy you can watch it on
amazon prime or apple or you can watch
it for free on youtube it's called
blowing the light my new special's out
now because this is coming out what
2027.
so i probably have a new special out i
i'm almost it's on youtube i'm sure so
go check that it's called mom love
uh that's great yeah i think it yeah
[ __ ] yeah good for you it's called mom
love check that out it's out and my
podcast long days with the honest pappas
all right giannis thank you very much as
always ryan zickler.com ryan sickler on
all social media we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you